sur les plages de zarziz comme chaque
matin chams eddine scrute l'horizon avec
dans son viseur les côtes libyennes à
une cinquantaine de kilomètres du
littoral tunisien pêcheur à la retraite
et bénévoles du croissant rouge tunisien
il assiste impuissant depuis 2003 un
sombre spectacle celui de corps d'homme
de femme ou encore d'enfant rejetés par
la mer une fin de voyage tragique pour
ces centaines de migrants qui après
avoir traversé le désert de libye
n'avait nul autre choix que celui de la
mer dans l'espoir de rejoindre les côtes
européennes
un scénario catastrophique dont il
renvoie la responsabilité à l'europe et
ses gouvernements dans leur inaction à
trouver des solutions concrètes
linaro fit mouche ce que j'ai fait ne
tient pas du hasard car non en tant que
pêcheur nous voyons depuis 2000 des
cadavres dans cette frontière maritime
entre la tunisie et la libye
et cette image macabre rester dans nos
mémoires ces corps sans vie d'hommes de
femmes et d'enfants
nous en tant qu'africains nous sommes
méprisés nous avons besoin de visa pour
voyager
par contre les européens n'ont pas
besoin de visa pour venir
voilà où est le problème au lieu de
protéger les frontières il devrait
commencer par protéger les gens pourquoi
mépriser ces gens ils prennent des
risques partent en mer risquent leur vie
c'est du 50 50 soit il meurt soit ils
survivent pendant longtemps
les corps sans vie de ces migrants
étaient enterrés dans une fosse commune
par les autorités tunisiennes une fin de
vie insupportables pour chems eddine qui
décida matin d'enterrer les corps
lui-même il décide en 2011 de rendre
hommage à ces voyageurs en leur offrant
une sépulture
une façon pour lui d'honorer leur
mémoire et d'alerter la communauté
internationale sur les ravages des
conflits qui secoue la région à quelques
kilomètres de sa plage il crée alors le
cimetière des inconnus un nom bien
évocateur comme pour marquer
l'impossibilité d'identifier ces
personnes nous l'avons appelé cimetière
des inconnus car ces gens là sont bien
des inconnues des inconnus chez eux des
inconnus durant leur traversée de la
libye et même des inconnus après leur
mort quand les enterre dans ce cimetière
je viens deux fois par semaine pour
entretenir les lieux avant il n'y avait
rien je viens donc planté des fleurs
nettoyer les tombes
car comme vous voyez c'est quelque chose
d'assez triste ces gens souffert dans
leur pays méprisé quand ils ont débarqué
en libye il meurt sans que personne ne
soit au courant et nous nous leur
rendons hommage on les enterre sans
regarder leur religion ou leur couleur
de peau ce sont des êtres humains point
barre il est donc humain d'entretenir ce
lieu est d'entretenir leur mémoire je ne
suis pas un héros
les héros ce sont eux dany en les
mettant en terre il a une pensée pour
leurs familles qui ne seront jamais si
leurs enfants sont encore en vie
chams eddine prône l'existence de son
cimetière multi religion pour lui qu
importe la religion encore la couleur de
peau
tous ont le droit de reposer en paix
garant de ce cimetière de fortune il
continuera sa mission humanitaire dans
l'espoir un jour d'arrêter de compter
les morts que rejette sur sa plage la
méditerranée